Also, das haben die sehr professionell hingekriegt,
ja, die Arme sind ausgebreitet.
Er macht sich im Prinzip schön breit…
Also es gibt einige Leute, die haben schon ein bisschen Knack im Kopf...
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Seit dieser Woche ist der neueste Teil der
Assassins’s Creed-Reihe draußen, Valhalla
heißt der und darin kann man sich als Anführerin
oder Anführer eines Wikinger-Clans durchs
England des neunten Jahrhunderts schlagen. Schön blutig, mit Axt, Schild oder Schwert.
Wer die Reihe jetzt noch nicht kennt, bei
Assassin's Creed geht es um die Jahrhunderte alte
Feindschaft zwischen zwei Geheimbünden:
Assassinen gegen Templer.
Dieser Kampf wird über verschiedene
Epochen der Geschichte ausgetragen.
Die Handlung spielt also zum Beispiel zur Zeit der Kreuzzüge, des alten Ägyptens oder der französischen Revolution.
Das Team von GameStar hat da einen ganz coolen
Überblick und ein Ranking gemacht, das verlinke ich Euch hier oben.
Aber sagt Ihr mir doch mal, was Euer Lieblingsteil denn ist. Lasst mal einen Kommentar dazu da.
Bei Assassin’s Creed wird sehr viel Wert auf historische Korrektheit gelegt.
Ich habe mir gedacht okay, echte Schauplätze, reale Figuren der Zeitgeschichte, historische Ereignisse, schön und gut.
Aber mich als NERD interessiert doch vor allen
Dingen…
„Warum liegt hier eigentlich Stroh?“
Strohhaufen sehen wir im Spiel ganz häufig, nämlich beim "Leap of Faith", dem Todessprung
der Assassinen, wo die aus krassen Höhen runterspringen - in so einen Haufen - und ich habe mich gefragt, ob das in echt funktionieren würde?
Könnten die Assassinen das überhaupt überleben?
Und ist die Menge an Stroh, die uns da präsentiert wird, dafür überhaupt ausreichend?
Das alles finden wir jetzt raus und natürlich muss uns auch jemand so einen Sprung vormachen.
Aber auch wenn ich im Urlaub schon mal gern von Klippen oder Brücken runterspringen,
an solche Höhen traue ich mich dann doch
nicht ran.
Muss ich aber auch gar nicht, denn wir lassen das einen Profi machen.
Wir schicken einen richtigen Berserker in
die Tiefe, den Todessprung aus 10 Metern
Höhe, den performt für uns Stuntman Mario Eichendorff.
Seit 30 Jahren ist Mario Stuntman für Live-Shows und Filme.
Er wurde schon von Treppen gestürzt, vom
Auto angefahren und durch die Luft geschossen,
sein krassestes Erlebnis aber: angezündet werden.
Mario, Du musst heut ausgleichen, was ich mich nicht traue. Cool, dass Du das machst, vielen Dank!
Bitte, bitte!
Bist Du vor so einem Sprung noch aufgeregt?
Aufgeregt nicht, man hat Respekt. Man macht sich jetzt warm, und dann geht's los.
Bevor wir Dich da jetzt hoch schicken, lass
uns noch mal kurz über diese Szene aus dem
Valhalla-Teil schauen, da springt der Protagonist Eivor von einem irre hohen Kirchturm runter.
Und ich finde, das sieht erst mal sehr professionell aus, wie er das macht. Aber ist das auch so?
Ist das eine gute Haltung?
Also das haben die sehr professionell hingekriegt. Die Arme sind ausgebreitet.
Er macht sich schön breit, hält auch lange
die Höhe und landet zum Schluss auf dem Rücken.
Und durch diese breite Armstellung kann er
im Prinzip seine Landung auch steuern.
Wie lange braucht man, um so eine Drehung
raus zu haben, die wirst Du ja nachher für uns auch machen?
Ja, wie gesagt. Das sind Erfahrungswerte für die Drehung, weil man versucht, so lange wie möglich senkrecht zu bleiben.
Im letzten Augenblick dreht man ein, fängt
oft kleiner Höhe an.
Steigert dann immer weiter nach oben und ich sage mal ungefähr drei Jahre müsste man
schon üben, damit dass wirklich sicher ist.
Also Können ist eins aber die Sicherheit, das bei jedem Sprung, wieder reinzubekommen,  das ist die zweite Sache.
Mario, Du musst dich doch ein bisschen vorbereiten. Das heißt, wir sehen Dich gleich wieder.
Und dass man Sprünge aus viel größeren
Höhen überleben kann, mit einer guten Polsterung, das zeigen folgende Fälle:
Zum Beispiel Ivan Mkhailovich Chisov. Er war Leutnant der sowjetischen Luftwaffe im Zweiten Weltkrieg, sein Bomber
wurde von einem deutschen Kampfflugzeug abgeschossen und er ist dann mit einem Fallschirm auf dem
Rücken, 7.000 Meter über dem Boden aus dem Flugzeug gesprungen.
Er hat aber aus Angst vor den Deutschen den Fallschirm nicht aufgemacht, ist dann auch
noch ohnmächtig geworden und unten auf einem Hang aufgeschlagen, der zum Glück aber mit Schnee bedeckt war.
Deshalb konnte er kurze Zeit später, zwar
schwer verletzt, aber immerhin lebend geborgen werden.
Und er hält bis heute den Rekord des höchsten, ungebremsten freien Falls.
Dann gab es da noch den Fallschirmspringer Michael Holmes, bei dem der Fallschirm technisch versagt hat.
Also der hat sich nicht richtig geöffnet
und er ist aus 3.600 Metern ungebremst Richtung
Boden gestürzt und dann glücklicherweise in einem Brombeerbusch gelandet.
Klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber da ist er
tatsächlich „nur“ mit einem gebrochenen
Knöchel und kollabierten Lunge davongekommen.
Und wenn wir jetzt von der Höhe her noch
ein bisschen mehr an unserem Beispiel von
Assassin's Creed rankommen wollen, dann können wir uns noch einmal den Fall von Thomas Magill angucken.
Der hat sich 2010 aus dem 39.  Stock eines Hochhauses in New York gestürzt, ist dann 120 Meter gefallen und durch die
Heckscheibe von einem Auto auf die Rückbank des Autos geknallt.
Also in dem Fall hat ihm das tatsächlich das Leben gerettet. Er hat sich bei dem Vorfall „nur“ beide Beine gebrochen.
Aber wie man an diesen ganzen Beispielen sieht, da geht es wirklich nur um das reine Überleben.
Also schwere Verletzungen sind da immer mit dabei.
Wenn die Assassinen jetzt aber aus diesem
Strohhaufen einfach so aufstehen und weiterlaufen wollen,
wie sie das im Game ja machen, dann
müssen wir denen eine weiche Landung garantieren.
Und ob das funktioniert, das müssen wir rauskriegen.
Also ist Assassin’s Creed physikalisch genauso korrekt wie historisch?
Diese Frage kann uns nur einer beantworten, nämlich unser „Stamm-Physiker“ Henry
…
mit dem ich im Vorfeld schon mal telefoniert habe.
Hi Henry!
Hi Jack!
Du hast Dir die Szene im Vorfeld schon mal
angeschaut.
Der Strohhaufen, den wir da sehen, der ist
so schätzungsweise 1,5m hoch.
Wie kriegen wir denn jetzt raus. ob das ausreicht, um diesen Todessprung von unserem Wikinger Eivor abzufedern?
Es ist erstmal wichtig, dass wir wissen, aus
welcher Höhe der überhaupt los fällt.
Je höher, desto mehr Stroh braucht er. Aber die Höhe wissen wir leider nicht.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen blöd, weil in Assassin’s Creed ja ganz häufig reale Gebäude mit verwendet werden,
also die beschäftigen extra Historikerinnen
und Historiker, um die Spiele möglichst authentisch
in die jeweilige Zeit zurückzuversetzen.
Aber hier haben sich die Leute aus unserem
Team echt Mühe gemacht, wir haben historische
Karten von England gewälzt, aber wir haben
dieses Gebäude tatsächlich nicht gefunden.
Also Fakt ist, das ist eine Kirche aus dem England des neunten Jahrhunderts und die steht im Örtchen Norwich.
Wenn Ihr also einen heißen Tipp habt, dann
schreibt das doch mal gerne in die Kommentare.
Und Henry, Du hast da einen physikalischen
Workaround für uns.
Klar, auf jeden Fall. Und zwar kann man das machen wie in unserer Super-Mario Folge.
Wir müssen einfach nur wissen, wie lange
braucht er denn, um zu fallen und zusammen
mit der Erdbeschleunigung können wir dann
herausfinden, aus welcher Höhe er gefallen ist.
Ich habe mir die Szene aus dem Spiel mal angeguckt.
Er fällt 3,8 Sekunden, ungefähr, und zusammen mit der Erdbeschleunigung von 9,81 m/s² kommt raus,
dass er aus einer Höhe von 71 Metern los fällt.
71 Meter? Das ist mehr als 7x so hoch was unser Stuntman machen muss.
Das ist ziemlich krass, die Höhe allein reicht aber noch nicht. Wir brauchen noch ein paar andere Annahmen.
Genau. Wir brauchen nämlich die Masse von Eivor und der Typ sieht ziemlich stabil aus.
Ich nehme mal an, der wiegt gute 90 Kilogramm.
Und außerdem brauchen wir noch die Fläche, auf die sich die Wucht des Aufpralls sozusagen verteilt.
Und da nehmen wir mal an, dass das so die
Hälfte seiner Körperoberfläche ist, er landet ja auf dem Rücken.
Da nehmen wir mal an, das ist ein guter m².
Ja und dann gibt das Stroh natürlich auch
noch nach. Das ist ja der Gedanke dahinter.
Wie kann man das physikalisch festhalten?
Darüber haben Sie sich mal ein paar Studierende der Uni Leicester Gedanken gemacht und zwar
haben die das im Journal of Physics veröffentlicht.
Was man dazu braucht, ist der sogenannte Kompressionsmodul.
Der gibt an, wie viel Druck man braucht, um einen Körper, um einen bestimmten Wert eben zusammenzupressen.
Und je größer dieser Wert eben ist, desto
schlechter lässt er sich zusammenpressen.
Wir haben das mal unter der Annahme gemacht, dass das Stroh sich unter einem bestimmten
Gewicht um 10% sozusagen zusammenpresst.
Und da kam raus, dass das Stroh ein Kompressionsmodul von 7.350 Pascal hat.
Und dann wird Eivor beim Aufprall auch noch abgebremst.
Genau, auf den wirken Kräfte, wenn er da
unten aufkommt.
Das ist das, was wir immer als G-Kräfte bezeichnen.
Da gibt es super unterschiedliche Angaben
darüber, wie viel ein Mensch aushalten kann.
Für Euch mal zur Einordnung: Alexander Gerst sagt, dass Astronauten bei einem Raketenstart
etwa 4,5 G ausgesetzt sind, also fast dem
Fünffachen ihres eigenen Körpergewichts.
Aber Henry unsere Assassinen, das sind ja
auch super trainierte Leute.
Das heißt, die können das locker ab, oder?
Genau. Diese 4,5 G, die wirken über einen längeren Zeitraum aber dieses abbremsen, das funktioniert ja sehr, sehr schnell.
Und über so eine kurze Zeit, das nehmen die
auch in diesem Paper an, da kann man gut 25 G
aushalten und kann danach noch weiterlaufen, wenn man eben wie die Assassinen sehr trainiert ist.
Super! Dann lass uns doch einfach diesen Wert übernehmen und das alles - wie immer - in eine große Formel packen.
Genau! Da nehmen wir diese hier und das setzen wir ein: die Höhe aus der er los fällt, die
Erdbeschleunigung g, die Beschleunigung mit, der er abgebremst wird, seine Masse, die Fläche,
auf der er landet und das Kompressionsmodul des Strohs.
Okay! 1,5m sind es im Game, Henry! Wie viele sind es bei Dir?
Wenn man das ausrechnet kommt raus, dass wir mindestens 9m Stroh bräuchten, damit er da wieder leben rauskommt.
Und das ist 6x so viel wie im Spiel.
Wow, okay. Also physikalisch alles nicht ganz so korrekt
wie historisch.
Da hatte Ubisoft im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes tief gestapelt und Eivor wäre nach diesem Sprung auf jeden Fall zermatscht!
Henry, danke fürs durchrechnen und bis bald!
Sehr gern, bis bald!
So Leute, Physikstunde ist vorbei. Jetzt kommen die richtigen Sachen!
Es ist super kalt heute und Mario friert sich
schon so ein bisschen den Hintern ab.
Mario, ist alles cool bei Dir?
Einwandfrei, kann losgehen!
Sieht auf jeden Fall sau hoch aus.
Ich hoffe, dass alles gut geht.
Ich zähle ein! 3… 2… 1… Go!
Krass!
Würde Ihr Euch das trauen? Ich nicht.
Mario! Sah mega cool aus! Wie geht’s Dir jetzt?
Ja gut, hat Spaß gemacht.
Business as usual… Unser Physiker Henry, der hat Deinen Sprung hier, die 10 Meter auch noch mal durchgerechnet.
Und der hat rausgekriegt, dass wir für diese
Höhe genau den Strohhaufen bräuchten, den
wir da in der Valhalla Szene sehen. 1,5m würden für diese Höhe ausreichen.
Würdest Du da immer noch reinspringen?
Herr nee, nee. Weil das hängt auch damit zusammen, wenn das Stroh schief steht, es muss ja ein bisschen
flauschig sein, dann bildet sich sowas hier. Wenn Du das zusammendrückst, das tut richtig weh.
Das piekt dann zu sehr.
Es ist wie ein kleiner Strohhalm oder ein Streichholz, was Dir in den Rücken bohrt. Nee muss ich nicht haben.
Alles klar, da schicken wir beim nächsten
mal den Physiker vor!
Wenn wir das zusammenfassen wollen, dann sind die Todessprünge der Assassinen physikalisch und theoretisch möglich.
Man müsste halt nur den Haufen ordentlich
nach oben stapeln, damit dass auch wirklich safe ist.
Aber so, wie wir es in der Szene präsentiert
bekommen, die 1,5m.
Das reicht „nur“ für unsere zehn Meter,
die wir hier gemacht haben.
Mario, dann vielen Dank, dass Du uns das so cool vorgemacht hast an Dich und deine Leute von Action and more.
Dank geht auch raus an die MedienakademieThüringen.
Bei denen waren wir hier zu Gast.
Und Netflix macht demnächst eine Serie zu
Assassin’s Creed.
Das heißt, da werden eine Menge Stuntmänner und Stuntfrauen diese Sprünge noch mal nachmachen.
Wenn Ihr Bock habt, Stuntmänner oder Stuntfrauen zu werden, dann schaut man auf der Website
der Medienakademie vorbei, denn da kann man sich dazu ausbilden lassen.
Ansonsten freue ich mich natürlich, wenn
Ihr noch einen Kommentar da lasst, wie fandet
Ihr die Folge, wie fandet Ihr diese Zusammenarbeit und was für Themen habt ihr eigentlich noch?
Welche Filme, Serien, Games können wir denn für Euch durchspielen?
Würde mich freuen, das zu lesen. Und was ist noch ganz wichtig, Mario?
Ganz wichtig ist abonnieren und Glocke drücken!
Dann können wir uns nämlich in 14 Tagen
wiedersehen. Ich freue mich drauf bis dahin!